what's the meaning of life was sassa
uh what is this why why are we here why
why why
was it uh the meaning of life wasn't
didn't they explain it at the end of
meaning of life I think it was Michael
Palin that said uh try to get a walk-in
uh be nice to neighbors uh eat enough
fiber wasn't that the fiber fibers part
of it yeah I think it's I think it's
nutrition I have Ebola brand in the
morning and uh don't take yourself too
seriously
yeah no well no one gets out alive I
think is the Hermann Hesse one of my
favorite writers he's a Nobel Prize
winner
um in in a book called Steppenwolf says
learn what is to be taken seriously and
laugh at the rest well that's awesome
what's the percentage Distribution on
that so how much of life should you take
seriously and then how much do you just
laugh at oh man if you can laugh at
everything you're you're winning yeah uh
but that's almost impossible I think
that there's there's uh and also could
be quite irresponsible to do that
I take things I take a lot of things way
too seriously I know that uh
I do I do I really do people will be in
part surprised by that but I think that
radiates from you really yeah I do I
take things way too [ __ ] seriously
sometimes but um yeah you're gonna
loosen the neck up yeah but uh no I
think that's that's really good that's
that's really good stuff it I don't know
what the percentage is to have a good
life or or or uh or a happy healthy life
but
you know for me the meaning of life is
getting to live it as long as you hope
to that's nice and
um and when you're when you lose someone
or or if perhaps you're faced with your
own mortality I think that puts that
into perspective and uh
but I you know get lots of vibe get lots
of fiber uh be nice to everybody and uh
yeah don't take things too seriously is
a good it's a good one our minds are
[ __ ]
big weird
it's a big weird shitty [ __ ] bucket
of [ __ ] that's trying to get you to
think horrible [ __ ] about yourself all
the time shitty bucket of [ __ ] shitty
bucket of [ __ ] it has a book I never
read but I read the title and it's good
words to live by which is uh don't sweat
the small stuff and it's all small stuff
that's another way is that Dr Phil
wasn't Dr Phil was I don't know but I
think the conclusion is also has fiber
that's part of it I think it all that
all ties it together and in the end of
course
just put love out there in the world
I think that's a pretty good way what
would you say is the meaning of life put
love on the world I would say love yeah
yeah yeah yeah it's a it's a long
conversation what that really means uh
but I'm sure robots are involved yeah
well let me tell you I feel a little
safer knowing that someone who has a
hand in
bringing these robots to the masses as
you do has that uh opinion of of love
and how important it is I think that's
great because uh otherwise it's going to
be that uh [ __ ] scene from T2 where
uh Linda Hamilton's holding on to the
the fence and getting all of her flesh
blown off of her skeleton before the
rest of hers is wiped away because this
Skynet [ __ ] anyway I'm just terrified of
doozy all the time that's why I think
that they will uh dudes in the wrong
hands can do a lot of damage that's why
Chad and I need to con do our best to
control it I need to travel back in time
and murder Chad
I think yeah that's yeah that's the only
way it's been said I don't know why you
need to travel back in time but
uh I will murder him today but I think
that'll be very suspicious my nefarious
plans for Chad involve going back to
tomorrow and planning for yesterday and
then and hopefully doozy will give me
the answer there with what what it is to
do with uh Chad's frozen body if I gotta
drive it out to if I got to take my uh
you know if I gotta get get a hold of it
like a one of those uh Tesla mom Vans
and uh shove my garage freezer in it and
plug it in and shove Chad in there drive
out to Arizona and deliver him under a
mountain or wherever the [ __ ] this place
is and say Here's this dog tag what does
this get me and they're like ah it's
gonna be uh 300 bucks if you have a do
you take AMEX no and I'll be like ah
[ __ ] and I'll just dump them somewhere
breaking bad stuff
well I would like to thank you and the
what is it the Canadian International
agency apparel Canadian for National
apparel I can't wait uh for the sneakers
from doozy I can't wait for all the uh
all the uh the podcasts
uh that AI can and all the trouble can
get you in so I'm a huge fan of yours
it's a huge honor that you would talk
with me today well this has been amazing
cheers pal likewise and I'm happy to be
here man cheers
oh that was three hours dude holy [ __ ]
what